hey good humans do you love our spectrum
videos if so we now have a game where
you can play it at home with your
friends and family you can answer
questions like this
dress codes are sexist see what your dad
says
we can end it right now
[Music]
um my name is christian st peter i'm
from long beach california i work for
the north american collegiate league
which is a non-profit collegiate esports
league what character are you i'm luffy
d monkey
for one piece for me it's the
entertainment factor it's not even
necessarily about wanting to be a
character or anything like that but like
the way other people react to you
um is what does it for
[Music]
you wanna try guessing each one
oh wow i'm gonna do terribly
number one i see purple boots i have no
idea first thought that comes to mind is
somebody who rides a motorcycle no idea
why second is definitely annabelle which
is a horror movie third sailor moon
i have no idea fourth
i'm kind of scared of her with those
boots on to be honest um i'm gonna be
careful what i say to her and then fifth
is
nasiku i forget but it's the uh
sister from demon slayer i'm also
probably wrong about that
we have the most important question
coming up early
what is your favorite anime
sailor moon
quick and to the point all right
uh number two kake guri
keke guri i haven't seen that one but
i'll add it to my list
um i really like no game no life because
it's what got me into singing annie song
and japanese music oh so you're about to
bust out with bluebird right now or ah
we can we can end it right now
[Applause]
all right number four
okay confession time oh i'm not a huge
anime fan don't kill me okay not huge
not huge what you want not huge okay i'm
but i do have a favorite anime all right
there we go and that is inuyasha i love
music okay i used to stay up saturday
night
trying to force myself to stay awake to
watch that episode on the cartoon
network yes i love that i think inuwasha
was probably my first one too that i
like remember watching oh yes number
five oh one piece is my favorite anime
um happy 1000 episodes by the
way what's your favorite anime um
so this is gonna come to a shock when
y'all come see me but it's actually not
rudo
yeah i'm on burrito right now still so
i'm still watching it as it's coming out
oh man
i'm gonna feel bad no matter who comes
out
well first of all y'all are all lovely
let me say that thank you
um
so
i'ma just have to get rid of number one
i'm sorry
get wrecked i would never ride a
motorcycle in my life i'm sorry you're
totally fine
huh your costume's amazing thank you
and uh i mean yeah the only reason i got
rid of you is i really just didn't feel
anything yeah no problem and i thought
you have a really cool voice are you a
baritone
i i'm just a dude
okay well it's nice
[Music]
okay um
bit different things than what i was
expecting
like the chain
i do see like the bottom of like a
french maid's outfit yeah and some
purple coming out
not entirely sure yet and then number
three it reminds me of pepe lapu so
that's a thing
i'm just getting attacked by colors
right now um and it's a good thing i
like to have a tail oh and the tail that
i did not see
looks like a monster's ink
they'll do that
i myself are coming out of a very
long-term relationship so what is the
longest relationship that you've been in
the longest relationship i've been in is
was three years and then number two so
my longest relationship was three years
that
ended in my first year university at the
end of my first year of university and
then number three my longest
relationship has been about eight months
actually that relationship ended in
2017.
[Music]
i
am just really looking for someone who
we really complement one another and we
have a lot of compatibility and then i'm
number four my longest relationship was
also three years
[Applause]
he broke up with me and you know
no don't be sorry
but i feel like it was actually a
blessing to me you know finding my
independence going back to childhood
hobbies like anime of course cosplaying
i had always wanted to ever since middle
school and you know i've explored so
many things so many creative outlets
like streaming on twitch you know in my
free time
um this one's gonna pain me but uh i'm
afraid i have to get rid of number three
okay
bye i love you
oh
i'm sorry storm it's okay obviously only
being in an eight-month relationship i
would have liked to hear bigger number
okay but you're gorgeous and i love your
outfit
and you're handsome too i appreciate it
i'm hurt it's fine it's it's fun
[Music]
why do you cosplay i cosplay because i
like to feel
like the character that i'm trying to
cosplay for example like i mean
realistically i can't be a gremlin in
real life but i love that movie the
gremlins and i want to be greta from
gremlins overall my style is already you
know very much creative and artistic so
i think that
when i cosplay i kind of feel like it
kind of satisfies my
you know creativity uh so we did number
two i almost feel like more
like
myself or that i can be myself when
i'm
in cosplay like when i'm with other
people who are cosplaying and they
recognize my cosplay i just get filled
with so much positive energy and i feel
like i can radiate that positive energy
to others and then uh number three i
cosplay because life is too short to
look basic
thank you
why is this too short
if you
were in an mmorpg or if you were
characterizing your sims you would not
want to look basic i actually stream in
my cosplay actually same you do oh no no
way yes way oh my god actually when i
mainly wear it you know if you guys
don't mind uh are you able to do like
the best impression of your character
um
all right this is i'm sorry this makes
video reading cringe um hi i'm yumiko
hi yamiko
number
and then uh number three it'll be our
little secret
or
what i don't want to but we don't have
to
so the first one i'm going to eliminate
is number one
[Music]
it's like a
gambling type of thing yeah no i've seen
like the cover of it probably yeah you
should watch it definitely i'll add it
on the list yeah it was nice to meet you
okay thank you
can we get a drumroll
so the next one i'm eliminating is the
current number one oh so that's me
yeah i'm sorry
hi hi
well you look great thank you so much no
problem and i'm so happy you're saying
bluebird for me oh thank you
i'm happy always happy to sing
appreciate it
seem pretty cool seem pretty cool i
appreciate that yeah i also really love
your cosplay that's awesome i tried
yeah
thank you so much
are you ready to see your final pick
i'm ready
lucy i'm coming
all right oh wow that's a lot going on
it looks great
what's your name brandi brandi christian
there we go do you have discord i'll add
you why are you trying on discord i do
oh my god we have so much in common we
do you guys exchanging twitches instead
of phone numbers yeah you know
phone numbers for old people it's all
discord
you might be in her dms i'm on her
discord what couple's costume do you
think you guys could pull off i can be
bow a handcuff
that'll work you're luffy i mean it
would work out
going on a date potentially
definitely esports lounge
please yeah let's go
[Music]